the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi having already studied area and
volume and its relationship to calculus
today we turn our attention to the study
of length and this may seem a bit
strange because intuitively I think it's
fair to assume that you would imagine
that length would be simpler than area
which in turn would be simpler than
volume and hence that perhaps we should
have started with length in the first
place the interesting thing is in terms
of our structure which we sulfa have
called two-dimensional area
three-dimensional area and which today
we shall call one-dimensional area a
rather peculiar thing that causes a
great deal of difficulty intellectually
speaking occurs in the study of arc
length that does not occur in either the
study of area or volume and I think that
will start our investigation today
leading up to what this really means so
as I say I call today's lesson
one-dimensional area which is Auckland
and let's show that there is a parallel
at least in part between the structure
of arc length and the structure of area
and volume you may recall that the area
our initial axiom was that the building
block of area was a rectangle and four
volumes the building block we saw was a
cylinder for arc length I think it's
fairly obvious to guess what we're going
to say the basic building block is a
straight-line segment and so without
further ado that becomes our first rule
our first axiom axiom number one we
assume that we can measure the length of
any straight line segment okay that's
our building block the second axiom that
we assume is that the length of the hall
equals the sum of the lengths of the
parts in other words if an arc is broken
down into constituent pieces the total
arc length is equal to the sum of the
arc lengths of the constituent parts and
at this stage we can say so far so good
this still looks like it's going to be
the same as area or volume but now
remember what one of the axioms for both
area and volume were namely what that if
region R was contained in region s the
area or the volume of our was at least
as was no greater than that
of the area or volume of s however for
Auckland this is not true
it need not be true I shouldn't say it's
not true it need not be true that if
region R is contained in s that the
length the perimeter of region R is less
than or equal to the perimeter of s in
fact this little diagram that I've drawn
over here I hope will sort of show you
what I'm driving at
notice this rather clear that the region
R here which is shaded is contained
inside the region s which is my
rectangle and yet if you look at the
perimeter here all these finger shaped
things in here I think it's easy to see
that the perimeter of our exceeds the
perimeter of s and if it's not that easy
to see heck just make a few more loops
inside here and keep wiggling this thing
around until you're convinced that you
have created this particular situation
all I want you to see here is that we
it's plausible to you that we cannot
talk about lengths by squeezing them as
we did areas and volumes between regions
that we already knew contain the given
region and were contained in the given
region now let me just pause here for
one moment to make sure that we keep one
thing straight we're talking now about
an analytical approach to length in
other words an approach that will allow
us to bring to bear all of the power of
calculus to the study I don't want you
to forget for a moment that intuitively
we certainly do know what arc length is
just as we intuitively had a feeling for
what area and volume were just too fresh
in our memories on this remember the
intuitive approach that if you have a
curve a an arc from A to B the typical
way of measuring the arc length is to
take for example a piece of string lay
it off along the curve from A to B after
you've done this pick the string up and
then straighten the string out whatever
that means and measure its length with a
ruler and we won't worry about how you
know whether you're stretching the
string too taut or what have you
we'll leave out these philosophic
questions all we'll say is is look at we
would like a more objective method that
will allow us to use math
medical analysis and so what we're going
to try to do next is to find an analytic
way that will allow us to use calculus
but at the same time will give us a
definition which agrees with our
intuition and the first question is how
shall we begin
and the so often is the case in
mathematics we begin our new quest by
going back to a an old way that worked
for a previous case and hopefully we'll
find a way of extending the old
situation to cover the new now what does
this mean in this particular instance
well
that's called let me just call it this
I'll call an analytical approach trial
number one what I'm going to do is try
to imitate exactly what we did in the
area case for example if I take the
region R which I'll draw this way here
if this is the region R namely bounded
above by the curve y equals f of X below
by the x-axis on the left by the line x
equals a and on the right by the line x
equals B how did we find the area of the
region R well what we did was is we
inscribed and we circumscribed
rectangles and we took the limit of
these circumscribed rectangles etc and
put the squeeze on as n went to infinity
now the idea is we might get the idea
that maybe we should do the same thing
for ah clangs in other words let me call
one of these little pieces of arc length
Delta W in other words I'm just
isolating PI of the diagram here his
Delta W his Delta X his Delta Y see the
idea is in the same way that I
approximated a piece of area by an
inscribed in the circumscribed rectangle
why can't I say something like well let
me let Delta W be approximately equal to
Delta X and just to make sure that our
memories are refreshed over here notice
that Delta X is just the length of each
piece if the segment from A to B namely
of length B minus a is divided into n
equal parts see ya there is why can't we
mimic the same approach and let me point
out what is so crucial here in terms of
what I mentioned above namely notice
that the reason that we can say that the
area of the region R is
the limit of youth sub n as n approaches
infinity where u sub n is the area of
the circumscribed rectangles the only
reason we can say that is because we
squeezed a sub R between L sub n the in
scrub the inscribed rectangles and u sub
n the circumscribed rectangles and the
limits of these lower bounds and upper
bounds were equal a sub R was squeezed
between these two hence it had to equal
for common limit that was the structure
that we used to see on the other hand we
can't use that when we're dealing with
Ock lengths and I'll mention that in a
few moments again but let me just point
out what I'm driving at this way suppose
we mimic this as we did before and we
say okay let the element of arc length
Delta W be approximately equal to Delta
X and now what I will do is define
script L from A to B I don't want to
call it ah clang because you see it may
not be but as a first approximation let
me define this symbol to be the limit of
the sum of all these Delta X's when we
divide this region into n parts as n
goes to infinity now look at I have the
right to make up this particular
definition now if I compute this limit
what happens
recall that we mentioned that the Delta
X was B minus a over N consequently if I
have n of these pieces the total sum
would be what n times B minus a over N
and n times B minus a over N is just B
minus a in other words script out from A
to B is defined and it's B minus a
naught W in other words coming back to
our diagram notice what happened what we
wanted was a recipe that would give us
this length here what we found was a
recipe that gave us the length from A to
B now intuitively we know that the
length from A to B is not the arc length
that we're looking for in other words
what we defined to be script out existed
as a limit but it gave us an answer
which did not coincide with our
intuition since we intuitively know what
the right answer is
we must describe this approach in the
sense that doesn't give us an answer
that we have any faith in and by the way
this where we went wrong over here if
you want to look at it from that point
of view notice that when we
approximately Delta W by Delta X it's
clear from this diagram that Delta X was
certainly less than Delta W but notice
that we didn't have an upper bound here
or we can make speculations like maybe
Delta X plus Delta Y would be more than
Delta W and things like this we'll talk
about that more later but for now all I
want us to see is the degree of
sophistication that enters into the
auckland problem that didn't bother us
in either the area or the volume
problems namely we are missing now the
all-important squeezed element well no
sense crying over spilt milk we go on
and we try the next type of approach in
other words what we sense now is look at
why don't we do this instead of
approximating Delta W by Delta X why
don't we approximate Delta W by the
court that joins the two endpoints of
the arc in other words I think that we
begin to suspect intuitively that
somehow or other for a small change in
Delta X Delta s should be a better
approximation to Delta W than Delta X
was of course the wide open question is
granted that is better is it good enough
well we'll worry about that in a little
more detail later all we're saying is
let Delta W be approximately equal to
Delta s in other words we'll approximate
Delta W by Delta s and will now define L
from A to B L from A to B to be the
limit not of the sum of Delta X is now
but the sum of the Delta s is as K goes
from 1 to n taken in the limit as n goes
to infinity and for those of us who are
more familiar with Delta X's and Delta
Y's and the symbol Delta s bothers us
simply observe that by the Pythagorean
theorem Delta s is related to Delta X
and Delta Y by Delta s squared equals
Delta x squared plus Delta Y squared so
we can rewrite this in this particular
form in other words I will define
capital air L hopefully to stand for
length later on but we're worried about
that later to the L from A to B to be
this particular limit
and now I claim that there are three
natural questions with which we must
come to grips the first question is does
this limit even exist does this limit
exist and the answer is that except for
far-fetched curves it does you really
have to get a curve that Wiggles
uncontrollably to break the possibility
of this limit existing unfortunately
there are pathological cases one of
which is described in the text
assignment for this lesson of a curve
that doesn't have a finite limit when
you try to compute the arc length this
way just a little idiosyncrasy however
for any curve that comes up in real life
that doesn't oscillate too violently
with infinite variations that set for
etc which we won't again talk about
right now the idea is that list limit
does exist as far as this course is
concerned we shall assume the answer to
question one is yes in fact the way
we'll do it without being dictatorial is
we'll say look at if this limit doesn't
exist we just won't study that curve in
fact we will call a curve rectifiable if
this limit exists and so we'll assume
that we deal only with rectifiable
curves in other words that this limit
does exist question number two okay the
limit exists so how do we compute it and
that in general is not a very easy thing
to answer what's even worth though is it
after you've answered this you have to
come to grips with a question that we
were able to dodge when we studied both
area and volume namely the question is
once this limit does exist and you
compute it how do you know that it
agrees with our intuitive definition of
arc length in other words if you recall
what we did just a few minutes ago we
defined script L from A to B to be a
certain limit we showed that that limit
existed the problem was is that limit
even though it existed did not give us
an answer that agreed intuitively with
what we believed arc length was supposed
to mean in other words you see we've
assumed the answer to the first question
is yes now we have two questions to
answer how do you compute this limit
which is a hard question in its own
right secondly once you do compute this
limit how do you know that it's going to
agree with the intuitive answer that you
get for arc
and this shall be what we have to answer
in the remainder of our lesson today
let's take these in order and let's try
to answer question number two first the
idea is we've defined capital L from A
to B to B this particular limit and we'd
like to know if this limit exists not
only that but we have a great command of
calculus at our disposal now all of the
previous lessons can be brought to bear
here to help us put this into the
perspective of what calculus is all
about for example when I see an
expression like this I'd like to think
in terms of a derivative derivative
reminds me of Delta Y divided by Delta X
etc so what I do here is I factor out a
delta x squared in other words I divide
through by Delta x squared inside the
radical sign which is really the same
equivalently as dividing by Delta X and
I multiplied by Delta X outside in other
words factoring out a delta x squared
the square root of Delta x squared plus
Delta Y squared can be written as the
square root of 1 plus Delta Y over Delta
X squared times Delta X now the idea is
that Delta Y over Delta X is the slope
of that court that joins the two
endpoints of Delta W it's not a
derivative as we know it it's the slope
of a straight line chord not the slope
of a curve now the whole idea is this
look at we know from the mean value
theorem that if I curve is smooth there
is a point in the interval at which the
derivative at that point is equal to the
slope of the court in other words if F
is differentiable on a B we may invoke
the mean value theorem here abbreviated
as MVT the mean value theorem to
conclude that there is some point C sub
K in our Delta X interval for which
Delta Y over Delta X is F prime of C sub
K and in order to help you facilitate
what we're talking about in your minds
look at the following diagram this is
all we're saying what we're saying is
here's our Delta X his our Delta Y we'll
call this point X sub K minus 1 this
point X sub K this is our case petition
Delta Y divided by Delta X is just the
slope of this line say that's just the
slope of this line and what the mean
value theorem says is that this curve is
smooth
some place on this arc there is a point
where the line tangent to the curve is
parallel to this court okay and that's
what I'm calling the point C sub K C sub
K is the point at which the slope of the
curve is equal to the slope of the court
in other words if F is continuous I can
conclude that the length from L from A
to B is the limit as n approaches
infinity summation K goes from 1 to n
square root of 1 plus F prime C sub K
squared times Delta X and notice notice
that this now starts to look like my
definite integral according to the
definition that we were talking about in
our earlier lectures in this block in
fact how can we invoke the first
fundamental theorem of integral calculus
remember if this integrand here
or if this expression here is not an
integral yet happens to be a continuous
function then we're in pretty good shape
in other words if I can assume that F
prime is continuous let's go over here
and continue on here see what I'm saying
is if I can assume that F prime is
continuous well look at the square of a
continuous function is continuous the
sum of two continuous functions is
continuous and the square root of a
continuous function is continuous in
other words and this is a key point if
the derivative is continuous I can
conclude that the L from A to B can be
replaced by the definite integral from A
to B square root of 1 plus dy DX squared
times DX which I quickly point out may
be hard to evaluate in other words for
one thing I could try to do over here is
to find the function G whose derivative
with respect to X is the square root of
1 plus dy DX squared and evaluate that
between a and B I can put approximations
on here whatever I want all I'm saying
is that if if I could summarize it down
here if F is differentiable on the
closed interval from A to B and if F
prime is the derivative you see
prime is also continuous on the closed
interval from A to B then not only does
this capital L from A to B exist but
it's given computationally by this
particular integral and that answers
question number two that the limit
exists and this is where it's equal to
the problem that we're faced with and
I've written this out I think it looks
hotter than what it says but I've taken
the trouble to write this whole thing
out so if you have trouble felling what
I'm saying that you can see this thing
blocked out for you the idea is this
what we have done is we have
approximated Delta W by Delta s then
what we said is look at W is the sum of
all these Delta WS and since each Delta
W is approximately Delta s then what we
can be sure of is that W is approximated
by this sum over here now here's what we
did we didn't work with W at all after
this we turned our attention to this
this is what we did in our case here and
we showed that this limit existed we
show that the limit as K went from 1 to
N and then went to infinity of these
pieces here was L of a B and that
existed what we did not show is that
this limit was W itself see intuitively
you might say look at if I put the
squeeze on this doesn't this get rid of
all the error for me we haven't shown
that we've gotten rid of all the error
see in essence how do we know if all of
the error has been squeezed out this is
precisely what question 3 is all about
again going back to what we did earlier
remember when we approximated Delta W by
Delta X then we said okay add up all
these Delta X's and take the limit as n
goes to infinity we found that that
limit was B minus a which was not the
length of the curve in other words
somehow or other even though the limit
existed we did not squeeze out all the
error and this is why the study of akka
lengths is so difficult because we don't
have a sandwich in effect it is very
difficult for us to figure out when
we've squeezed out all the error so at
any rate let me generalize question
number 3 where I bring out that member
request
number three is how do we know that if
the limit exists its equal to W all I'm
saying is don't even worry about a claim
just suppose that W is any function
defined on the closed interval from A to
B and that we've approximated Delta W by
something of the form G of C sub K times
Delta X where G is what I call some
intuitive function defined on a B for
example in our earlier example we
started with Delta W being a clang and
we approximated Delta W by Delta X in
which case G would have been the
function which is identically 1 in the
areas situation remember we approximated
Delta a by something times Delta X well
what times Delta X well it was the
height of a rectangle in other words we
look at the thing we're trying to find
we use our intuition and this is
difficult because intuition varies from
person to person and we say what would
make a good approximation here what
would be approximation we say okay let's
approximate Delta W by G of C sub K
times Delta X where C at some point in
the interval etc then we add up all of
these Delta WS as K goes from 1 to N we
say ok that's approximately this thing
over here now what we have shown is that
if G is continuous on a B then as n goes
to infinity this particular limit exists
and is denoted by the integral from A to
B G of X DX see this is what we've shown
so far what the big question is is
granted that this limit exists does it
equal W in other words is W equal to the
integral from A to B G of X DX that's
what the remainder of today's lesson is
about as far as arc length is concerned
and I'm going to solve this problem in
general first and then make some
applications about this - arc length
itself and by the way what we're going
to see next if you may remember that
very very early in our course we came to
grips with something called
infinitesimals we came to grips with
this delta y-tan infinitesimal zuv
higher-order and now we're going to see
how just as this came up in differential
calculus the same crowd
of approximation come up in integral
calculus
the only difference as we've mentioned
before is instead of having to come to
grips with the indeterminate form zero
over zero we're going to have to come to
grips with the indeterminate form
infinity times 0 let me share what I
mean by that see the idea is this let's
suppose that our case Delta W were
broken up W now into increments and
let's suppose that we're approximating
Delta W as we said before by G of C sub
K times Delta X well what we mean by
we're approximating this what we mean is
there's some error in here let's call
the error alpha sub K times Delta X in
other words this is just a correction
factor this is what we have to add on to
this to make this equality hold you see
once I add on the error I'm no longer
working with an inequality I'm working
with inequality equality and that allows
me to use some theorems see what I can
say now is look at by definition W is
the sum of all these Delta WS but Delta
W being a sum we can use theorems about
the Sigma notation in other words what
is the sum of all these Delta WS it's
the sum of all of these pieces plus the
sum of all of these pieces which I've
written over here and now you see if I
transpose I get that W minus this sum is
equal to the sum K goes from 1 to N
alpha K times Delta X now the next thing
I do is take the limit as n goes to
infinity by definition since G is the
continuous function this limit here is
just the definite integral from A to B G
of X DX on the other hand this limit
here is what we have to investigate in
other words we would like to know
whether W is equal to the definite
integral or not if we look at this
particular equation what we have now
shown is look at whatever the
relationship is between these two terms
it's typifies by the fact that this
difference is this particular limit in
other words if this limit happens to be
zero then the integral will equal what
we're setting out to show it's equal to
namely this function itself on the other
hand what we're saying is we do not know
that this limit is zero by the way knows
what's happening over here
goes to infinity Delta X is going to
zero in other words each individual term
in the sum is going to zero but the
number of pieces is becoming infinite
there's your infinity times zero form
here and let me show you a case where
the pieces are growing too fast and
number to be offset by the fact that
their size is going to 0 for the sake of
argument let me suppose that alpha sub K
happens to be some nonzero constant for
all K if I come back to this expression
here if alpha sub K is equal to a
constant I'll replace alpha sub K by
that constant which is C I now have what
that the limit that I'm looking for is
the sum K goes from 1 to n C times Delta
X taking the limit as n goes to infinity
C is a constant so I can take it outside
the integral sign since C is a constant
and it's outside the equal sign let's
look at what Delta X is Delta X is B
minus a divided by n same as we're
talking about earlier in the lecture
I have n of these pieces the N in the
denominator cancels the N in the
numerator when I add these up and notice
that this particular sum here no matter
what n is is just B minus a in other
words in the case that alpha sub K is a
constant
notice that this limit is C times B
minus a C is not 0 B is not equal to a
we have an interval here therefore this
will not be 0 and notice that if this is
not 0 if this is not 0 these two things
here are not equal and by the way you
see the aside that I would like to make
here is that even though alpha sub K
even though this error is not negligible
notice the fact that if alpha sub K is a
constant so that's Delta X goes to 0
this whole term will go to 0 but it
doesn't go to 0 fast enough in other
words eventually we're taking this sum
as n goes to infinity and here's a case
where what the pieces went to 0 but not
fast enough to become negligible well
let me give you something in contrast to
this situation number 2 is suppose
instead alpha K is a constant times
Delta X beat
times delta x would be is a constant in
that case notice that our summation K
goes from 1 to N alpha K times Delta X
is just summation K goes from 1 to N B
times Delta x squared now keep in mind
again that Delta X is still B minus a
over N so Delta X squared of course is B
minus a over N squared notice that
what's inside the summation sign here
does not depend on K it's a constant I
can take it outside the summation sign
how many terms of this size do I have
while K goes from 1 to N so I have n of
those pieces therefore this sum is given
by this this is an N squared term one of
the ends in the denominator cancels with
my N in the numerator and in this
particular case I find that the sum as K
goes from 1 to N alpha sub K times Delta
X is B which is a constant times B minus
a squared which is also a constant
divided by n now look at if I now allow
em to go to infinity my numerator is a
constant my denominator is n as n goes
to infinity my denominator increases
without bound my numerator remains
constant so the limit is 0 in other ways
in other words in the case where alpha
sub K is a constant times Delta X this
limit is 0 the error is squeezed out and
in this particular case W is given by
the integral from A to B G of X DX
exactly in this particular situation
well the question is how many situations
shall we go through before we generalize
and the answer is since this lecture is
already becoming quite long let's
generalize now without any more details
and the generalization is this in
general if you break down W into
increments which we'll call Delta W sub
K and Delta W sub K is equal to well
I've made a little slip here that should
be a G in here I'm using G's rather than
FS if Delta W sub K is G of C sub K
times Delta X plus the correction factor
alpha K times Delta X and for each K the
limit of alpha K is Delta X approach
zero is zero in other words what we're
saying is that alpha sub K times Delta X
must be a higher-order infinitesimal if
this is a higher-order infinitesimal if
alpha K goes to 0 as Delta X goes to
zero that says what that alpha K times
Delta X is going to 0 much faster than
Delta X itself see compare this with our
discussion on infinitesimal x' earlier
in our course I think that was in block
2 but that's irrelevant here but all I'm
saying is if that is the case in that
particular case the limit that integral
is exactly what we're looking for the
error has been squeezed out in other
words now in conclusion what we must do
in our present problem to answer
question number 3 remember we have shown
we have approximated Delta wk by this
integrate little thing 1 plus F prime C
sub K squared times Delta X in other
words in our particular illustration in
this lecture the role of G is played by
the square root of 1 plus F prime
squared what we must show is that this
difference is a higher order
differential and this really requires
much more advanced work than we really
want to go into the only trouble is as a
student I always used to be upset when
the instructor said the proof is beyond
our ability or knowledge whenever they
used to say the proof is beyond our
knowledge at this stage of the game I
used to say to myself he doesn't know
how to prove it I think there's
something upsetting about this so what
I'm going to try to do for a finale here
is to at least give you a plausibility
argument that we really do squeeze the
error out in our approximation of Delta
W in this case in other words let me
draw this little diagram to bring in the
infinitesimally idea here see here's my
Delta W here's my Delta s and what I'm
doing now is I am going to take the
tangent line to the curve at a have seen
use that rather than Delta X now what
I'm going to say is look at Delta we're
going to assume that our curve doesn't
have internal oscillations so I can
assume the special case of a monotonic
increasing function use the intuitive
approach that in this diagram Delta W is
caught between Delta s and a B plus BC
observing that BC is just what's called
Delta Y minus delta y-tan you see and
that by the Pythagorean theorem a B is
the square root of Delta x squared plus
Delta Y sub tan squared which of course
can be written this particular way
namely notice that the slope here is the
slope of this curve when X is equal to X
sub K minus 1 and again this is written
out so I think you can fill in the
details as part of your review of the
lecture and your homework assignment all
I want to do here is present a
plausibility argument using a B a C and
Delta s as they occur in this diagram
all we're saying is look at if we're
willing to make the assumption that this
curve has the right shape Delta W is
squeezed between Delta s and a B plus BC
as we showed on our little inset here a
B is the square root of 1 plus F prime
evaluated X sub K minus 1 squared times
Delta X what is BC remember BC was Delta
Y minus Delta Y 10 that's just your
epsilon Delta X of your infinitesimal
idea where the limit of epsilon as Delta
X approaches 0 is 0
fact let me just come over here and make
sure we write that part out again
remember what we saw was the delta y-tan
was dy DX evaluated at the point in
question plus what an error term which
was called epsilon Delta X where epsilon
went to 0 as Delta X went to 0 and
that's all I'm saying over here in other
words where is Delta s squeezed between
right now C doubt welcomed with this way
Delta s itself by definition is a square
root of Delta x squared plus Delta Y
squared that we saw was this that was
our beginning definition in fact
now if you look at our diagram once more
notice that since our curve is always
holding water and rising that the slope
of the line Delta s is greater than the
slope of the line a be putting all of
this together we now have Delta W
squeezed and it was not at all trivial
in putting the squeeze on Delta W you
see there was no self-evident way of
saying just because one region was
contained in another it must have a
smaller arc length we really had to be
ingenious in how we put the squeeze in
to catch this thing but in the long run
what we now have shown is what that
Delta W is equal to this with an error
of no greater than epsilon Delta X in
other words the exact Delta W is what
it's the square root of 1 plus F prime X
sub K minus 1 squared Delta X plus Alpha
Delta X where alpha can be no bigger
than Epsilon
though this is the maximum error that we
have here because it's caught between
this well look at as epsilon approaches
as Delta X approaches zero so goes
Epsilon and since alpha is no bigger
than Epsilon
it must be that as Delta X approaches
zero so does alpha approach zero in
other words if we now write Delta W in
this form observe that in line with what
we're saying this is a higher-order
infinitesimally as a result the
intuitive approach can be used as the
correct answer you see the idea is we
could have said earlier look why don't
we approximate the arc length by the
straight line segment that joins the two
endpoints of the arc and the answer is
you can do that but you are really on
shaky grounds if you say it's
self-evident that all the error is
squeezed out in the limit this is a very
very touchy thing in other words in the
same way that zero over zero is a very
very sensitive thing in the study of
differential calculus
infinity times zero is equally as
sensitive in integral calculus the whole
upshot of today's lecture however is now
that we've gone through this whole hard
approach it turns out that
we can justify our intuitive approach of
approximating the arc length by straight
line segments at any rate this concludes
our lesson for today and until next time
goodbye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate